of a renewed invasion
and this time the force arrayed on
ukraine's frontier comprises over a
hundred thousand troops far bigger than
anything russia has deployed against her
before
if the worst happens and the destructive
firepower of the russian army were to
engulf ukraine's towns and cities i
shudder to contemplate the tragedy that
would ensue
ukrainians
have every moral
and legal right to defend their country
and i believe their resistance would be
dogged and tenacious
and the bloodshed comparable to the
first war in chechnya or bosnia mr
speaker or any other conflict
that europe has endured since 1945
no one would gain from such a
catastrophe
russia would create a wasteland in a
country which as she continuously
reminds us is composed of fellow slavs
and russia would never be able to call
it peace
for months britain has worked in
lockstep with the united states and our
allies across europe to avoid such a
disaster we've sought to combine
dialogue with deterrence
emphasizing how a united western
alliance would exact a forbidding price
for any russian incursion into ukraine
including by imposing heavy economic
sanctions
and at the same time we stand ready as
we all raise
as we always have to address any
legitimate russian concerns through
honest diplomacy
on the 13th of december
i spoke to president putin
and i stressed that nato had no thought
of encircling or otherwise threatening
his country
and that russia enjoyed as much right as
any other state to live in peace and
security
but as i said to him
russia of ukraine also
enjoys an equal and symmetrical right
to that of russia and i said that any
attack
on his neighbor
would be followed by tougher sanctions
against russia further steps to help
ukraine defend herself and by an
increased nato presence to protect our
allies on nato's eastern flank
the truth is that russia's goal is to
keep nato forces away from her borders
then
if that is russia's goal then invading
ukraine could scarcely be more
counterproductive
my right honourable friends the foreign
and defense secretaries have both
conveyed
the same message
to president putin and i'm prepared of
course to speak ready to speak to him
again
meanwhile the american deputy secretary
of state met her russian counterpart in
geneva on the 10th of january in the
nato russia council gathered two days
later as the house knows the american
secretary of state anthony blinken met
the russian foreign minister last friday
and the u.s administration has confirmed
president biden's willingness to have
another meeting with president putin
continuing the bilateral dialogue they
began last year but credible deterrence
is the other side of the coin
last night i held a virtual meeting with
president biden president macron
chancellor schultz president uh duda
prime minister draghi general secretary
uh stoltenberg president michelle and
president of wonderland
we agreed that we would respond in
unison to any russian attack on ukraine
in unison by imposing coordinated and
severe economic sanctions heavier than
anything we have done before against
russia
and we agreed on the necessity of
finalizing these measures as swiftly as
possible in order to maximize their
deterrent effect
we in the uk
will not hesitate to toughen our
national sanctions against russia in
response to whatever president putin may
do and the house will soon hear more on
this from my right on my friend the
foreign secretary
we've already declassified compelling
intelligence exposing russian intent to
install a puppet regime in ukraine
and we will continue to disclose any
russian use of cyber attacks false flag
operations or disinformation
amid all these pressures
ukraine
asked for nothing except to be allowed
to live in peace
and to seek her own alliances
as every sovereign country has a right
to do
last week the uk acted to strengthen uk
ukraine's ability to defend her soil by
supplying anti-armor missiles
and deploying a small training team of
british personnel in addition to the
work of operation orbital which as the
house will know has trained 21 000
ukrainian troops since 2015.
yesterday we took the responsible
precaution of temporally withdrawing
some staff and dependence from the
british embassy in kiev though i
emphasize that the embassy remains open
and will continue to provide consular
assistance for british nationals in
ukraine and i'm particularly grateful
for the dedication of our ambassador in
kiev melinda simmons
[Music]
i commend our nato allies for the steps
they've taken undertaking to protect the
eastern flank of the alliance denmark is
sending a frigate to the baltic and
deploying four f-16s to lithuania to
join nato's long-standing air policing
mission
france has expressed its readiness to
send troops to romania under nato
command
and the united states has raised the
alert level of 8500
combat troops preparing to deploy them
in europe at short notice
the british army leads the nato battle
group in estonia
and if russia invades ukraine
we would look to contribute to any new
nato deployments to protect our allies
in europe
in every contact with russia the uk and
our allies have stressed our unity and
our adherence to vital points of
principle
we cannot bargain away
the vision
of a europe whole and free
that emerged in those amazing years from
1989 to 1991
healing the division of our continent by
the iron curtain
we will not reopen that divide by
agreeing to overturn the european
security order
because russia has placed a gun
to ukraine's head
nor can we accept the doctrine implicit
in russian proposals that all states are
sovereign but some are more sovereign
than others
the draft treaty published by russia in
december would divide our continent once
again between free nations and countries
whose foreign and defense policies are
explicitly constrained by the kremlin in
ways that russia would never accept for
herself
more than half of europe including a
dozen or more members of nato and of the
european union
will be only partially sovereign and
required to seek the kremlin's approval
before inviting any military personnel
from nato countries onto their soil
the czech republic at the very heart of
europe hundreds of miles from russia
would have to ask the kremlin for
permission if she wanted to invite a
company of german infantry to join an
exercise or even to help with flood
defenses
there is nothing new
about large and powerful nations
using the threat of brute force to
terrify reasonable people into giving
way to otherwise completely unacceptable
demands
but if president putin were to choose
the path of bloodshed and destruction he
must realize that it would be both
tragic and futile and nor should we
allow him to believe that he could
easily take
some smaller portion of ukraine to
salami slice because the resistance will
be ferocious anyone who has been to kiev
as i have and stood by the wall of
remembrance studied the portraits of
nearly 4
500 ukrainians who've died in defense of
their country since 2014 the total death
toll stands in excess of 14 000
anyone who's been there will know that
the ukrainians are determined to fight
and have become steadily more skilled at
guerrilla warfare and if russia pursues
this path many russian mothers sons will
not be coming home
and the response in the international
community
would be the same
and the pain that will be inflicted
on the russian economy will be the
same when i spoke to president putin i
also reminded him
that at crucial moments in history
britain
and russia
have stood together
the only reason
why both our countries are permanent
members of the un security council
is because of the heroism of soviet
soldiers in the struggle against fascism
side by side with ourselves
i believe
that all of russia's fears could yet be
allayed and we could find a path to
mutual security through patient and
principled diplomacy provided that
president putin avoids the trap of
starting a terrible war and mr speaker a
war that i believe would earn and would
deserve the condemnation of history and
i commend this statement
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kia stammer
uh thank you mr speaker and can i thank
the prime minister for advanced side of
his statement
and i'm grateful to the defense
secretary for keeping the opposition
informed of developments throughout the
crisis
when the soviet union collapsed britain
russia and the united states
made a solemn agreement with ukraine
in exchange for giving up nuclear powers
and weapons ukraine's security was to be
guaranteed and its independence would be
respected
ukraine has kept its end
of the deal
president putin has not
his russia has annexed crimea
supported separatist conflict
in donbass
and now massed over a hundred thousand
troops on ukraine's borders
these are repeated and unjustifiable
acts of aggression
so labor stands resolute
in our support of ukraine's sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
that was made clear when our shadow
foreign secretary and shadow defense
secretary visited kiev a fortnight ago
and i made it clear to the ukrainian
ambassador when i met him last week
this isn't just a local dispute on the
other side of the continent
it's an attempt by president putin to
turn back the clock
to re-establish russian force as a means
of dominance over parts of eastern
europe
and it's a direct threat to the
anti-imperialist principle that
sovereign nations are free to choose
their own allies and choose their own
way of life
that is why it is crucial
that we in this house are united in
opposing russian aggression
so let me be clear the labour party
supports the steps that the government
has taken to bolster ukraine's ability
to defend itself
we support international efforts to
deter russia from further aggression and
the vital diplomatic efforts to
de-escalate the situation
can the prime minister assure the house
that during talks the uk and our
partners will be resolute in our defense
of ukraine's sovereignty and the
security of our nato allies
for too long the implicit message to
moscow has been that president putin can
do what he likes and the west will do
little to respond
we must now change course
and show russia that any further
aggression will result in severe
real-world consequences
for britain and our allies that will
mean taking tough decisions
that won't be easy
widespreading
widespread and hard-hitting sanctions
must include
cutting russia's access to the
international financial system
europe's over-reliance on russian energy
supplies is well documented and it
simply must be addressed
and in britain we have failed to rid our
economic and political systems of the
ill-gotten money used to support the
putin regime
if we take our obligations to global
security seriously we cannot go on
allowing ourselves to be the world's
laundromat for illicit finance
labor has a four point plan
really
first
reform companies house to crack down on
shell companies
second a register of overseas entities
to lift the veil on who owns property
and assets in the uk
thirdly tougher regulation of political
donations
and finally implement the
recommendations of the cross-party
russia support to bolster national
security
so i ask will the prime minister support
these measures to rid the uk
of the loot of the corrupt russian elite
we cannot stand up to russian aggression
abroad while facilitating russian
corruption at home
after the chemical attacks in salisbury
after the annexation of crimea
and now the threat of invasion in
ukraine
it's time to send a simple
clear and united message
we support ukraine's sovereign right to
choose her own destiny we will stand
with the ukrainian people in the face of
president putin's threats
his aggression will come at a high price
for himself
and his regime thank you mr speaker
prime minister mr speaker i thank the
right honourable gentleman and i must
say that i'm very glad that he supports
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of of ukraine and uh he is uh
he's right to ask uh about the
assurances that this country has given
to ukraine and i i must say that uh i
have repeatedly told uh vladimir
zelinski as i told his uh predecessor
pedro poroshenko many times we stand
four square behind the independence and
sovereignty of ukraine mr speaker and we
always will and we have a hard-hitting
uh package of sanctions ready to go uh
what i think would be fair to say is we
want to see our european friends are
ready to deploy that package as soon as
there should be any incursion at all uh
by russia into ukraine he asks about uh
what we're doing to track down uh
russian money in this country and in the
city as he knows we're bringing forward
measures for register of beneficial
interest mr speaker but i don't think
there's any country in the world that
has taken tougher action against the
putin regime it was this government that
brought in magnitsky sanctions against
all those all those involved in the
poisoning of alexey navalny mr speaker
and it was this government it was this
government that that got the world
together got 28 countries together to
protest against the poisoning that took
place in salisbury and the world
responded to that british lead mr
speaker by collectively expelling 153
diplomats around the world and what i
can tell him mr speaker i'm grateful to
him for the general tenor of his uh of
his intervention and for the support uh
that he is that he is giving uh to nato
uh belated that it may be from uh the
bench's opposite but i'm grateful for it
i'm grateful for it now mr speaker and
what i can tell him what i can tell him
now mr speaker
is that that same leadership in
assembling a response to russian
aggression is being shown by the uk now
and it is absolutely vital that the
world the west is united now because it
is our unity now that will be much more
effective in deterring any russian
aggression and that is what this
government will be pursuing in the days
ahead
to buy a cell would the ch
thank you mr speaker as the prime
minister articulates the west is now
regrouping but the penny is also
dropping the threat of sanctions will
not deter a russian this russian
aggression and a total or even partial
invasion will have severe economic and
security consequences felt right across
europe and beyond ukraine's grain
exports will be affected towards africa
global gas prices will be impacted and
skyrocket and where might and embolden
russia turn to next
so i ask the government to liaise with
the united states and now consider a
more simpler and effective option to
deter this invasion by relatively
answering ukraine's call for help
it is not too late to mobilize a
sizeable nato presence in ukraine
utilizing the superior hard power the
alliance possesses
to make putin think twice
about invading another european
democracy
prime minister i i thank him very much
and i know that he will uh emotionally
many people will uh share what uh my my
uh honorable friend says and and he he
knows
a great deal about ukraine and about the
the issues that country faces and of
course instinctively uh many people
would yearn uh to send uh active
physical uh support in the form of uh of
nato troops to to ukraine i have to tell
him that i don't believe that that to be
a likely prospect in the near term
ukraine is not a member of nato but what
we can do and what we are doing is
sending troops to support ukraine i've
mentioned the the training operations
that we're conducting under operation
orbital have done uh for the last uh six
or seven years uh trained twenty 000 uh
ukrainian troops uh and of course we are
now sending defensive weaponry mr
speaker defensive weapon which i think
is entirely appropriate uh two thousand
uh anti uh tank uh weapons uh to the
ukrainians uh and we join the americans
in that effort as he knows the americans
have said about 650 million dollars
worth of military assistance to ukraine
uh that is the a vital thing uh to do to
stiffen ukrainian resistance but i think
the real deterrent right now mr speaker
is that package of economic sanctions
that is what will bite that is what will
hurt putin and that i hope is what will
deter him
leader of the smp in blackford
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site obvious
statement and join with the leader of
the opposition and congratulating the
defense secretary who has made sure all
through this that we've been kept
informed of developments that's most
appreciated and it is important mr
speaker that all of us in this house
stand together in solidarity with our
friends in ukraine in defense of their
sovereignty
we on these benches share the deep
concern
over the escalation of tension the
prospect of military aggression and that
threat
to ukraine's sovereignty
russia's actions
in recent weeks and months of amassing
troops tanks and heavy military
equipment near the border of ukraine are
unacceptable
we continue to support above all
measures to resolve the crisis through
diplomacy
so while the prime minister provide
reassurance that work to deliver a
peaceful and diplomatic outcome remains
this government's main priority
the threat of bloodshed on european soil
is what's at stake
as we stand with the people of ukraine
and understand the fears and concerns of
ukrainians across these islands many of
them who live in the uk that have family
in ukraine the bedrock of nato as a
defensive alliance remains the
solidarity between its member states and
it is clear that we need that united
alliance
it is becoming increasingly apparent
that should an encouragement occur
what will be required is a tougher
package of sanctions that are robust
and that have real measurable impact
we on these benches have called for
coordinated economic sanctions against
the putin regime and the banning of
russia from the swift banking system can
this be confirmed as being on the table
today
these measures must also include tougher
action on russian money laundering and
include action by the treasury to tackle
the ongoing and improper use of scottish
limited partnerships which have been
used to funnel millions of pounds and
dirty money without this are incredible
credibility lessons and let me say to
the prime minister when he raised the
issue of oginski
it was cross-party support that led to
these sanctions and he may well remember
the meeting that i had with him when he
was foreign secretary to make sure that
we work collectively but to deal with
those threats
so while the prime minister also commit
to introduce a transparent system of
company registration and proper proper
reform of companies
meanwhile
we all stand
solidly with the people of ukraine and
urge the government to continue efforts
for diplomacy as long as that is
possible
mr again again mr speaker i'd like to
thank the right honourable gentleman to
echo many of his sentiments and he's
completely right to say that we should
pursue uh every possible diplomatic
avenue in every uh appropriate forum mr
speaker whether it's the the nato russia
council the un uh the osce the the g7
the normandy format uh we must we must
follow every avenue uh he's right to uh
to press on on what we're doing uh to to
track uh
dirty russian money for want of a better
uh expression that's why uh we have the
unexplained wealth orders and that's why
uh we're bringing in uh measures uh to
to have a register of beneficial
interest he asks about swift and and
financial transactions across the world
and uh there is no doubt that that would
be a very potent uh weapon i'm afraid it
can only really be deployed uh with the
assistance of the united states though
uh we are in discussions about that i
think the house needs to understand that
one of the big issues that we all face
in dealing with uh ukraine and in and in
dealing with russia is the heavy
dependence of our european friends in
particular on on russian gas and uh it
was clear in the conversations last
night that that in this era of high gas
prices we are bumping up against that
reality so the job of our diplomacy now
is to persuade and encourage our friends
to go as far as they can uh to sort this
out and to come up with a tough package
of economic sanctions because that is
what the situation requires show the
select committee tom two gundam foreign
affairs mr speaker my right honourable
friend will remember when he was foreign
secretary the foreign affairs committee
published a report entitled moscow's
gold about dirty russian money flowing
through our system and the call for us
to have various registers of not only
ownership but also foreign agents
operating within our system we've had a
reminder only a week ago of why this is
so important would he
tell me what he is doing to work with
partners across europe to make sure that
we stand together and do not just act as
a voice outside the kremlin but make
sure that putin's acolytes who have
profited from his kleptocratic regime
actors voices inside the kremlin telling
putin what he is risking because the
impressive work that the defense
secretary has done in helping to support
our ukrainian friends could be
undermined
if the kremlin doesn't listen to the
very real danger that it faces today uh
well prime minister mr speaker it is
absolutely right that the best way to uh
to to get attention in the kremlin and
in moscow generally is to have sanctions
that are directed at the individual uh
like magnitsky sanctions for instance
but that is the uh that is what we will
be coming forward uh with as well as
sanctions are
directed at companies mr speaker that
are of crucial strategic russian
interest
chris brown thank you mr speaker in kiev
and kramatorsk last week we met
politicians and community leaders who
will not only be worrying for the future
of their country but we will be worrying
for their
well they'll be fearful for their own
lives
and i've been arguing for a very long
time that the arguments that president
putin uses about
russian speakers in ukraine are exactly
the same as adolf hitler advanced over
the sudetting germans
in czechoslovakia in the 1930s
i agree with the chair of the foreign
affairs committee that we do need to see
full implementation of the moscow gold
report
i'm sure there will be other sanctions
coming i don't quite understand why
we've only sanctioned 25 percent of the
people that the american government have
already sanctioned
[Music]
but this house will stand ready
alongside the prime minister if he needs
to introduce further legislation for
instance to seize russian assets in the
uk
and to make sure that the unexplained
wealth orders which have only
worked in three cases in the last four
years
actually have an effect we stand ready
to stand by the ukrainian people prime
minister
i thank him very much and i think he's
completely right in what he says uh his
analysis of uh of russian uh certainly
of putin's intentions towards ukraine
i'm sure he's read the 5 000 word essay
by uh by vladimir putin about uh about
ukraine and the origins of uh of russia
it's clear uh what his uh psychological
uh what his emotional the wellsprings of
his uh thinking are uh on on sanctions
i'm grateful what he says uh we're
bringing forward as he knows a uh
statutory instrument greatly to to
toughen up uh the package of of our
ability to sanction people and i hope he
i will support him dr julian lewis thank
you mr speaker president putin hasn't
even waited for the gas to start flowing
through the nordstrom 2 pipeline before
exploiting the stranglehold that has
been building on the german economy my
right honourable friend has already
indicated that it may be difficult for
germany to impose severe sanctions
against russia if this invasion goes
ahead so does he not agree with me that
it is vital from our securities point of
view that anyone with strong russian or
communist chinese links should be kept
well away from our own critical national
infrastructure
prime minister of the my right on
offenders is completely right and uh
that's why we brought in measures to
protect our national security uh our
national uh infrastructure our critical
national infrastructure and uh
and to make sure that we are able to uh
stop investment that we think will be
detrimental uh to our national uh
security mr speaker and i'm afraid he's
quite right to also what he says about
uh the german uh dependence on uh on
russian gas we have to be we have to be
respectful of this the simple fact is
that the uk i think of our gas uh
supplies about three percent comes from
russia about thirty percent six percent
of german energy needs comes from
russian gas so they are in a very
different position from us uh their
sacrifice is potentially very large but
we must hope that in the interest of
peace they are willing to make that
sacrifice
can i thank the prime minister for his
statement it is right that we stand
united across the house to support
ukraine and to stand against russian
aggression which we should remember has
already resulted in over 13 000
casualties in the last few years
the prime minister's rightly talked
about gas being an issue in this debate
particularly on russia but indeed in
germany but across central eastern
europe and it will also potentially
impact this country with the threat of
increased gas price at a time when
farmers are already facing rocketing
heating bills so could i ask him to take
further action on energy as i did
during the russian invasion of crimea
and so alongside all the measures he
rightly proposed in his statement will
the prime minister convene a summit of
g7 energy ministers as we had back in
2014 to look at how we can improve
short-term and medium-term energy
security protect consumers in this
country and elsewhere against rocketing
gas prices and give ourselves a much
stronger hand in the face of putin's
aggression
prime minister i i thank him also by the
way mr speaker i think that much of the
work that he did on uh renewables when
he was in office was uh prescient and
and valuable for this country and it's
put us in a stronger uh position to to
resist the the russian gas uh blackmails
as i told the house just now uh we of
our gas supply is only three percent
comes from russia but he's also right
about the spike in prices that's why
we're working together uh with president
biden uh with other colleagues uh to to
see what we can do to increase the
supply of gas uh both to europe and to
and of course to this country as well
carl mccartney thank you speaker if
russia invades ukraine does my
right-hand friend see the potential as i
do that it will lead to a flood of
refugees crossing from the ukraine into
the eu so poland romania and slovakia
could see massive flows of displaced
people indeed that may be a part of
putin's thinking the eu is then so
distracted and full of infighting are
refugees that it cannot respond
militarily what does my honourable
friend think the response from brussels
is going to be maybe the polls should
have a bus state at the border crossing
ready to take them all to germany and
france especially given it is berlin and
paris that have watered down any nato
response thus far because if this
massive flow of refugees happens it may
well be the end of the eu
my honorable friend is is making a very
valuable point because of course
we have seen only recently how uh
refugees from belarus have been uh used
as uh of tools of political warfare and
we've got to be uh conscious of the
potential of
the uh the kremlin to trigger exactly
the kind of refugee crisis that he
describes
kevin jones thank you very much can i
thank the prime minister for his
statement and agree with him that uh
should putin invade ukraine
tough sanctions will be necessary but
the putin regime relies and exists
because it floats on an ocean of illegal
and illicit finance much of it that
flows through the city of london
now the prime minister just said that
the uk has the strongest uh laws against
uh the uh such illicit money i'm sorry
promise that's just not true just look
at what our allies in the united states
are doing yeah it is now time to attack
that that is the way to actually [ __ ]
this regime and can he tell me when he
is going to uh implement the russia
report and his recommendations because
as my right my honourable friend from
ronda said if that needs emergency
legislation to get it through let's do
it yeah prime minister i will mr i'm out
of debt to speak up again i i want to i
want to repeat what i uh he's right uh
that it's vital to guard against russian
dirty money's uh flowing through the the
world and he's completely right in his
analysis of the uh of the of the way uh
the kleptocracy works that's why we have
the uh unexplained uh wealth orders
that's why we're bringing forward a
register of beneficial interests and uh
having we have a new corporate defense
for failure uh to prevent tax evasion uh
madam deputy speaker and we will come
down and we do come down very hard on
all those uh who are exploiting uh the
city of london or anywhere else to wash
dirty money
mark pritchard
i welcome the prime minister strongly
underlining ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and just back in
november madame deputy speaker there was
no unanimity across europe increase even
across the atlantic on the issue of
ukraine that has changed since over the
last few months with the good offices of
of the prime minister's office defense
secretary
and foreign secretary he mentions uh his
conversation last night with chancellor
olaf schultz
the germans are a critical part of all
of this both on diplomacy and defense
they are a key international partner and
ally we can do it with the americans we
can do it with others but it will be far
more effective if we do it with the
germans
prime minister oh my honorable friend is
completely right and i just want to say
a word or two in praise of olaf schultz
because uh last night in conversation uh
with him it was clear as i've said to
the house how difficult this is for
germany nobody should be any doubt about
that but it was also clear that the the
new german chancellor is determined to
stand with the rest of uh the west to
have a united front and amongst other
things of course germany has made it
clear that nordstrom 2 cannot go they
can't uh take part in uh nordstrom 2 if
there's a russian invasion of ukraine
uh ben bradshaw
thank you mother deputy speaker the
prime minister is absolutely right to
say that western unity is key so could
you explain
why the uk began withdrawing some of our
diplomats from kiev this week unless
unlike most of the rest of nato
prime minister i i thank him uh we're
actually in lockstep with the united
states and as he knows uh we've kept at
least 30
of our of our diplomats
there including melinda simmons our
outstanding ambassador the uk presence
uh continues to to be very strong in in
kiev but those are sensible
precautionary steps
syrian duncan smith yeah
big speaker i'm gonna say to my
honourable friend first of all i
congratulate him and the defense
secretary of voluntary for a very robust
set of leadership uh with nato and our
european allies and with the united
states but does he not also agree that
right now we are facing an even wider
threat whilst it's ukraine today
the the powers of
of dictatorship have watched
as we did nothing over georgia over
crimea south ossetia and they've been
encouraged even now china is looking at
taiwan watching what our reaction will
be does he not agree now that we have to
get our allies to recognize we must
never put ourselves in the position when
it comes to energy such that we are
dependent on these terrible regimes for
our future we need to get security in
our energy now
my right honourable friend is is
completely right in what he says about
the need for us to
guarantee the independence of our of our
energy that's why it's so vital that
we're building uh our wind power and
other renewables uh so fast madame
deputy speaker but he's also right in
his
analysis of what is happening what putin
basically wants
is to go back to the the altar system
of of of spheres of of influence and
it's not just ukraine uh madam deputy
speaker that he has his eye on uh and
therefore uh this moment now matters for
the whole geometry and security
architecture of europe and we must stand
firm
order short and concise questions please
because i will be finishing this
statement at 20 past two hillary ben
thank you very much indeed madame deputy
speaker the military reality is that
president putin knows that if he invades
he will not be facing nato troops and
therefore
the sanctions we put in place have to be
the strongest possible is the prime
minister not concerned that given the
answer he just gave about
the mainstream 2 pipeline the fact
discussions are still continuing about
exclusion from the swift system
that we're not demonstrating determined
united resolve at the very moment where
we need the credible threat of strong
sanctions to try and deter him from
invading ukraine prime minister i i
thank you and i think his point is very
important actually i think that we are
making a huge amount of progress and i i
want to thank my writing friend the the
foreign secretary of defense secretary
for the work that they're doing uh uh
because i think we are bringing together
the west uh on a very tough package and
that's what we need
pops
thank you madam deputy speaker can i
remind the house we do actually
guarantee the sovereignty of ukraine
by having signed the budapest memorandum
in 1994 along with the united states and
russia and i think later france and even
china but could i ask my right honorable
friend
if he agrees with me
that if we really economically and
financially
strangle
russia with sanctions
russia could well become bankrupt and
this alone might be something to cause
mr putin to blink before he gives
agreement to using military power
and turning it into military force prime
minister um
my honorable friend is is completely
right that we have that we have the
potential uh to
do very serious economic damage to uh to
russia uh what we have to make sure as
everybody said on the call last night is
that we don't uh inflict damage on the
on the western economies uh just as
people are suffering in particular uh
from high gas prices and that's what
we've got to do and don't forget and
he's quite right 41 of russians russia's
gdp comes uh from oil and gas
alison taylors
speaker the truth about unexplained
wealth orders is that only a handful of
them have been issued and the
registration of overseas entities bill
has now been waiting for four years for
action so the fight when the finance
bill returns to this house will the
government bring forward measures to
tighten up on the flow of dirty russian
money in the uk or is the truth really
that he's perfectly content with this
because so much of it appears to end up
in tory party coffers
oh madam deputy speaker we do not accept
uh foreign donations as she knows uh
very well uh and what would and what we
will do is what we will do is bring
forward targeted targeted sanctions
which i think are the most effective way
of doing it uh targeting uh the
sanctions uh
the personalities that surround
president putin and making them
understand the price that they will pay
andrew morrison
madam deputy speaker there's no public
appetite for using uk combat troops in
ukraine absolutely none but we do have
other tools in our toolbox
is the prime minister contemplating
using the full spectrum approach to
cyber including offensive cyber that he
talked about in march in connection with
the uh integrated review prime minister
uh yes madam deputy speaker the ncsc the
national security cyber center is cyber
security center is indeed uh offering
help uh to ukraine for precisely uh that
purpose russian cyber taxes the house
knows can be extremely damaging and we
can do a lot to help
stephen kinnick thank you dr speaker the
government's position is that sanctions
will be deployed against russia if there
is an incursion but would the government
consider deploying some sanctions now
as a clear signal to russia
and to say if president putin stands
down his troops and withdraws his forces
then further sanctions will not be
deployed would that not be a more
effective sequencing of the
process i thank improved thoughtful
argument we already have as as
i've said madame deputies we've already
had magnitsky sanctions very sanctions
already uh in place on the uh on the
russian regime sanctions in response to
uh the the seizure of crimea and
sevastopol uh already in place a wide
variety of sanctions i think what we
need to do if i may say so is build up
that instant automatic package of
sanctions of western sanctions that will
come in automatically in the event of a
single toe cap of a russian incursion
into you into more of ukraine
jackie doyle prize
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
welcome the robust sentiment behind my
writing world friends statement and
indeed it's important that the unity
across this house is expressed in
opposition to putin if we are going to
make a reality of that but my radical
friend mentioned in his opening remarks
bosnia and he will be aware of the saber
rattling happening in republic of cersei
encouraged by russia he will also be
aware that there are there is still
occupy territory in moldova and could he
reassure me that these areas are also
under discussion with the allies
sir uh mr speaker my honorable friend
makes an excellent madame deputy speaker
makes an excellent point and uh
this this
crisis
around ukraine
uh is one that will be replayed across
the whole map of uh eastern europe uh
madam deputy speaker if we fail now and
if we don't stand up to putin she's
entirely right about what she says about
the balkans
james washington news it is two o'clock
you are listening to the prime minister
boris johnson answer questions on the uh
russian
ukraine situation uh let's listen back
into the comments nato and a true friend
of the uk
the primes have said that uh
if russia invades ukraine we will then
both strap our nato allies should we not
have more forces in estonia now
a very uh good point madam deputy
speaker we i've been to see the the 850
troops in in tapas i'm sure he has uh as
well they do a fantastic
job in in estonia uh what will what
we're looking to do is uh potentially to
increase our presence in uh in the
nato's south eastern flank as well
bernard jenkin
thank you madam deputy speaker can i
thank
my writer or friend for his statement
which puts the united kingdom at the
forefront of the response to president
putin's monstrous military intimidation
yeah and can he personally pledge
himself to the defense of the new
democracies of eastern europe who
suffered under the soviet yoke for so
long and still want to be free and will
he acknowledge that this cannot be a
change just if the invasion takes place
the change must happen anyway we must
make sure that we are prepared in a new
cold war against this kind of
intimidation until the russian regime is
removed
uh i i thank my right honourable friend
and i know that he speaks uh for many
friends and many good allies uh in in
eastern europe in in poland in the czech
republic
in the baltic states uh there are people
who would precisely echo his sentiments
and that's why we have to stand strong
and united today for ukraine
neil coyle i mean describes ukraine and
russia's equal parties and we know he
likes a party but he also said ukraine
scarcely known a day of peace since the
2014 russian invasion illegal annexation
indeed in december there were 128
shellings of of ukrainians indonesia and
three ukrainian souls have been murdered
by russian-backed forces since january
so the quest is why is he not acted
sooner and why is he even now saying we
must wait for full-scale invasion before
further sanctions including access to
swift and implementing the moscow gold
and russian report recommendations takes
place why wait prime minister uh i'm i'm
afraid that i think he the the iron
brother must miss what i already said uh
we we already have a very wide package
of sanctions in place uh since uh the
russian uh incursion of 24 of 2014. uh
we have sanctions of of
personal sanctions and other sanctions
for what they did in crimea and
sevastopol and uh and and what we're
going to do now is ratchet those uh
sanctions up very very considerably and
he's i'm afraid he's not writing what he
says about uh
leaving ukraine alone or abandoning
ukraine since 2014 operation orbit the
uk has been out there in the front uh
helping to train uh ukrainian troops uh
21 000 of them uh since 2015 madam
deputy speaker james sunderland
deputy speaker thank you the prime
minister will know of course that
ukraine is not a full member of nato but
could i please ask him to comment on the
feasibility of direct military action by
nato notwithstanding that article 5 does
not apply
prime minister
well i i thank him very much and i i
wanted really to to to uh
go back to the answer i gave to uh the
the writer magenton for bournemouth uh
i know that many people uh emotionally
will want to commit uh nato troops to
the to the defense of of ukraine we have
uk troops there now members of the of
the ranger regiment are going uh to
supplement those we already have uh but
i have to say uh that there is no member
of nato that is currently willing uh to
uh to deploy in uh in ukraine in in in
large numbers uh to fight uh russian
aggression in the way that uh he
suggests uh the the best thing and
indeed we have to beware of doing things
uh
speaker that would constitute a pretext
uh for putin to invade we have to
calculate and calibrate what we do very
carefully and i think building a strong
package of economic sanctions uh
continuing to supply uh defensive
weaponry uh and all the other things
that we're doing uh that's the right
package stuart jose
speaker the prime minister said we have
already declassified
a compelling intelligence exposing
russian intent
and he said
we will continue to disclose any russian
use of false flag operations
or disinformation
how much of that declassified
information
will be made fully public
so as to blunt or halt the spread of
russian disinformation
by letting people who see it
know that it's false
before they decide to press the share
or send button
well he makes an excellent point of
course because it's it's very very
important that
people in ukraine and around the world
should be able to trust the information
that we're uh giving out i have no doubt
that uh the intelligence that we shared
about the uh the the uh uh the coup
attempting uh in in kiev was was right
or the the people who are conspiring
against the regime was right uh but we
will we will divulge as much of our
sourcing as we can without compromising
uh our intelligence sources
alan cairns
speaker we are all naturally alarmed and
share concerns at the risks that uh
people of ukraine face but take
confidence from the prime minister's
statements and actions in helping
coordinate the western uh response but
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that nato must always leave the
door open for ukraine joining
yes prime minister
my right honourable friend is completely
right he puts his finger on the
fundamental point and the thing that we
cannot bargain away a sovereign country
must have the right to choose her own
destiny choose its own that that's what
uh ukraine uh must have of course uh the
the path to nato membership will not be
easy uh for anybody and and it's not no
one is saying that that is going to
happen
immediately but a country must be
allowed to choose its own way forward
and that's what we're worth sticking up
for stephen ferry
thank you very much
um any russian invasion of ukraine would
be a very serious breach of the terms of
the united nations charter in 2014 the
the seizure of crimea was discussed in
the security council i think on seven
occasions and eventually a resolution
was passed through the general assembly
which left russia extremely isolated so
what plans does the government have to
pursue this current crisis through the
the u.n and given the reality of a
russian veto on the security council to
perhaps look once against the general
assembly
i think uh the honourable general is
completely right and i think that that
it is an underestimated uh
point in our favor that i don't believe
in the end that russia wants uh the kind
of isolation uh that would ensue uh i
think russia does one of the global
institutions russia takes the um very
seriously russia values uh her
membership of the un security council
and i think uh what he proposes about
using the general assembly is entirely
right but it's very important that we
not only have tough measures but we also
provide the avenue for for diplomacy as
well
stevenson
thank you madam deputy speaker i want to
thank the prime minister for sending
such a strong and clear message um to
vladimir putin and and for everyone
across this house in backing the prime
minister on such a crucial issue uh at
such a worrying time can the prime
minister reassure british nationals in
ukraine that our embassy in kiev remains
open to provide assistance should they
require it mr
yes and i'm very happy to give that
reassurance as i've said just now the
embassy continues to function uh at
least 30 uh staff are there to look
after british interests in kiev and
around ukraine
mr speaker the kremlin does not act in
isolation it acts against the plan so
can the prime minister set out what
additional support we'll be providing to
our allies on nato's eastern flank
especially using uk forces that are
already stationed in those countries to
deter any future russian aggression
after any invasion of ukraine prime
minister thank you well he's he's he's
making a very important point that what
uh we all are discussing at the moment
is what we can do to fortify
nato's eastern southeastern uh flank the
french are looking at
romania uh there are there's a there are
questions about uh uh hungary and what
we might do uh about course uh uh there
are complex issues as he knows involving
the hungarian uh minority in uh in uh in
ukraine uh everybody uh can see the need
now to uh to move nato forces
particularly the americans you heard
what i said about the here what i said
about the 8500 uh troops are getting
ready uh to go to europe everybody can
see the need to fortify nato's eastern
flank richard drax
thank you madam deputy speaker the
diplomacy of the uh the velvet glove
must be supported by a steel fist if
it's to be effective
does this threat to nato indirectly
uh inform the prime minister that
perhaps nato must spend more money on
its conventional forces
and in that regard would he reconsider
the cut to our army of 10 000.
uh well madam deputy speaker we have uh
spent record sums on our wonderful army
and uh it is uh more agile more lethal
more deployable
around the world that's why we're able
to to move at speed to deploy not just
in estonia but as i was saying to the
gentleman opposite uh we will uh look to
move it look to move to other parts of
the uh of nato's uh eastern frontier as
well jim shannon thank you very much can
i thank the prime minister the mod and
fcdo uh secretary for their resident and
strong stance uk nato and usa have
committed trips to the balkans yesterday
to poland uh and to combat and stop
russian aggression summer support needs
to be given to the ukraine
and the pictures last week in the press
it showed the ukraine militia training
with wooden guns can i ask and very much
illustrates the david glass struggle can
the prime minister confirm that military
assistance and boots on the ground are
what is needed urgently and right now in
the ukraine thank you
yes i saw those pictures too of
ukrainians trade training ukrainian uh
civilians training with with wooden
weapons and i can tell him that we are
supporting the ukrainian uh army and
there is a a strong tradition now uh in
ukraine uh of of militias of people who
understand how to fight
a guerrilla war and i think the message
we need to get across to the russian
people is that this would be a disaster
for them in the political disaster for
vladimir putin jonathan ginoclay
thank you madam deputy speaker uh in his
very strong statement my right
honourable friend quite rightly spoke
about the need for western unity so of
all countries in europe it does seem
bizarre that germany needs to be
reminded that murderous dictators will
never be satisfied with a single land
grab and that any attack on ukraine is
an attack ultimately on all of europe
will my rightful friend be reminding the
germans of this prime minister i i thank
my right honourable friend and he and i
have discussed these types of issues
over many
years actually i think that given the
extreme uh delicacy of the matter in
germany given the dependence that i've
described to the house on uh on on
russian hydrocarbons actually i really
think that olaf schultz is doing a a
huge job of moving and getting us to a
position where we have united uh western
approach and that i i i commend the
german government mcdonnell i'm grateful
madam deputy speaker for reasons we
don't need to go over just now
germany has blocked some nato allies
from providing certain military
assistance
to ukraine what assessment has the
government made of that blocking and
where it is necessary for ukraine to
defend itself will the uk government
along with others ensure that it gets
the maximum spread of capability that
we're able to provide it with prime
minister well he makes a very important
point of course but as he as he knows
the and as i've told the house uh the
end laws that we we've sent uh in
addition to uh all the aid we've given
under operation although we're we're the
second biggest contributor uh to uh the
um
uh the defense of uh i stressed the
defense
of ukraine and i think it's i i saw a
poll uh of the ukrainian people uh which
said that the uk was now the most
popular uh government in uh ukraine uh
the foreign government second second
second
not not second only to the scott to the
scottish government and i don't know but
second only to lithuania madam deputy
speaker
robert henry
the uk has proven to be the preeminent
european nation in supporting and
defending the ukraine and so i thank my
writer my friend for his leadership on
that nobody could doubt our commitment
to european security and i've been
encouraged by the remarks he's already
made with respect to germany but it is
critical that the german government play
a full part if we're going to deliver
the unprecedented package of financial
and other sanctions that he's described
and was set out in the call last night
how confident is he of that and what
more can he do with chancellor schultz
to ensure that's delivered minister uh
he's right germany is absolutely
critical for our success in this uh we
we've just got to keep the pressure up
together alan moran
deputy speaker i heard what the prime
minister said earlier about introducing
a register for beneficial interests but
my question to him is when
because it's been six years that it was
promised at that dispatch box he said it
to the leader of the opposition six
years since it was promised nothing has
happened every moment we wait undermines
our position i've laid the bill it's got
support from both sides please will he
take it up we need to send the message
that cronies monies is not welcome in
this country stan
she's completely right but in addition
to the unexplained wealth orders and the
crackdown on uh on uh tax evasion uh we
do want to register a beneficial
interest and i can tell her that my uh
uh right or friend the leader of the
house tells me we will do as soon as
parliamentary time allows jason
mccartney thank you madam deputy speaker
i have a vibrant ukrainian community in
my corn valley constituency i met with
many of them earlier this month will the
prime minister please reassure my
constituents of our commitment to the
defence support package for ukraine our
readiness to unleash economic sanctions
on russia and also stand firm for
freedom and democracy alongside the
ukrainian people prime minister uh yes
uh madam uh deputy speaker and uh the
the uk has been at this for a long time
now and i think it was an important
signal that i hope you will take back to
his constituents that uh we stuck up for
ukrainian uh rights of navigation
when we send hms defender we through
that route if you remember we the
government came under some pressure from
uh people for taking what was described
as a provocative route all we were doing
madam deputy speaker was sticking up for
the rights of freedom of navigation for
the ukrainians
alan smith
thank you madam deputy speaker the
russian regime is a clear and present
danger to the rules-based international
order so the snp will be part of the
coalition in ukraine's defence but in
that spirit would the prime minister
accept the real frustration on this side
of the house that his own credibility
the credibility of his own government
and all of us has been undermined by
continued inaction and implementing the
moscow's gold report and the russia
report we would support the legislation
to strengthen his own credibility let's
get on with it
uh madame speaker i i don't think that's
fair the government has been absolutely
ruthless in uh implying magnitsky's
actions which uh his his right
honourable friend uh helped to uh help
to promote uh it was it was it was it
was my uh right on the front lawn
chancellor who uh who who who who
produced them uh they're a great thing
we've targeted uh people involved in the
poisoning of our lexi and navalny and we
will use direct targeted sanctions now
against against the putin regime
speaker ukraine has very strong
historical and cultural links to my
constituency of kensington with the
ukrainian embassy the cultural center
and the ukrainian institute all based in
holland park can my right honorable
friend assure me that we will do
everything to support the people of
ukraine in their desire to live in peace
prime minister
uh yes uh indeed
i'm familiar with the statue of uh i
think some voldemort uh in her
constituency and uh i i know the amazing
contribution of uh the ukrainian
community to our great capital and uh i
hope she will pass the message that we
stand foursquare with them and i'm casa
thank you madam deputy speaker a
percentage of our natural gas comes from
russia and putin has already said that
he'll turn off the taps if he deems
moscow to have been unfairly sanctioned
by the west my constituents of adrian
shots are already struggling with rising
fuel costs and that's why i voted in the
snp increasing cost of living debate
yesterday does the prime minister accept
that he must bring in a package of
policies to help families pay for bills
on the domestic front so that this
international issue does not compound
the problem prime minister uh well mrs
madden she's quite right to draw
attention to the the price spike in
energy around the world actually russian
uh gas only comprises three percent of
the uk's gas supplies but what we've got
to do is mitigate the uh the impacts on
families of of the costs of of energy
with the with all the cold weather
payments everything that we're doing uh
to increase the living wage all the
support that we're giving families uh
throughout uh throughout the winter and
beyond shout it farah
thank you madam deputy speaker and may i
commend the my right honourable friend
on his tough statement the point has
already been made about the
disinformation that is coming from the
kremlin but my right honourable friend
will appreciate that a lot of that is
targeted towards nato itself would he
use this opportunity to make it
absolutely clear that nato is a
defensive organization and that it
should not in any way be construed as
being offensive or threatening step yes
i i i thank my right honourable friend
and he is so right because that is
the misconception whether it is witting
or otherwise uh russia persists in the
fiction that nato is somehow an
aggressive alliance and a threat to
russia and nato is not an aggressive
alliance russia is not encircled uh by
threats and it is absolutely vital uh
that we convey that to vladimir putin
and i think if he can understand that
that is the route to progress and that
is the the diplomatic path we've got to
follow watching dr hughes
thank you madam deputy speaker the prime
minister will get every support for
defending national self-determination
from these benches within europe but
does he not agree it's no time that the
uk government signed a robust security
and defence agreement with the european
union to replace that signed in the
lisbon treaty critically article 42.7
prime minister you're working very
closely with you i i thank him actually
if you look at what's happening
the conversation that i had last night
with european partners comprised the
vast bulk of defence spending uh in the
west and we work very closely with our
european partners as we do with all our
nato partners and nato remains the
primary vehicle for our our defense and
nato is a very valuable interlocutor uh
with russia and the nato russia council
has proved its worth in the last few
months
there's the wake up call that nato needs
so that all its members finally meet
their obligations to spend at least two
percent of their gdp on defence yeah
prime minister uh my honorable friend is
completely right because i think
so many colleagues have said this is not
just about ukraine
this is about the ambition of of the
kremlin to seize this this moment uh to
try to reimpose a new order uh a new
security architecture in uh in the
european continent one that we
absolutely reject uh managers we stand
for the rights of free peoples
everywhere to determine uh their own
fate that was the fantastic achievement
of the end of the cold war the fall of
the berlin wall uh that high high moment
in 1990 when we had a europe hole and
free that's what we're trying to protect
last question margaret ferrier thank you
madam deputy speaker there are reports
of some ukrainians beginning to stock up
in non-perishable goods can the prime
minister confirm that the government has
plans in place to support provision of
necessities to ordinary ukrainian people
if necessary
of course we will do what we can to
provide economic support in the event of
a disaster but the most important thing
we can do now is try to prevent that
disaster from occurring that is by
unifying the west uh in the way that
i've been describing this afternoon
order i thank the prime minister for his
statement i'm sorry not everybody could
uh get in but we do have to move on to
the next business
order alistair carmichael
uh and that brings that part of today's
proceedings in the comments to a close
the prime minister boris johnson
delivering a statement on ukraine the
ongoing situation
on its border with russia the prime
minister accusing the russian president
vladimir putin of having his eye on
other former soviet nations to rebuild
what he described as the country's old
sphere of influence uh we'll have more
on what unfolded in the house of commons
throughout the afternoon here on sky
news
a reminder of our top story what
promised to be a tough week already for
the prime minister today got
considerably worse britain's most senior
police officer has confirmed that
scotland yard will be investigating
allegations of parties held in downing
street during pandemic lockdowns the
criminal investigation has already
requested the cabinet office hand over
relevant information from the sue grey
inquiry and that much anticipated
investigation
could be delayed we understand until the
met have completed their work although
sky news understands
this may not be the case let's hear what
the commission